[Music]
so gorgeous how are you feeling feeling
good a source tells et Mariah Carey has
shed at least 30 pounds since having
weight loss surgery last November and
apparently it has nothing to do with the
gym our source says Mimi's slimmer look
is thanks to her gastric sleeve and a
new diet she's really only eating salmon
capers and plain chicken broth and the
occasional glass of wine quote she is
very confident about her appearance now
the change to her diet was an adjustment
at first for her but she's doing really
well keeping up with it she's in a very
good place with her health and her life
all eyes were on Carrie when she hit the
red carpet at Sunday's Golden Globe
Awards the blonde beauty rocked a
body-hugging gown by Dolce & Gabbana in
support of The Times up movements all
black dress code protesting gender
inequality and sexual harassment the
Grammy winner told et she's ready to
lead the charge for change in the music
industry even like in the music business
we haven't even touched that I know what
it is but I think I need to be a
consultant when it's time to talk about
that
[Music]